hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled advancement in uti
testing a multi-omics approach this
webinar is part of the clinical
diagnostics and research event and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinth and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific for more information please
go visit our sponsor site at
thermofisher.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to first
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during this presentation
you can find that chat located at the
right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you'd like during
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker
dr david banak
a cso and co-founder of pathnostics for
a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top left of your screen dr burnoff you
may now begin your presentation
thank you i'd like to
thank thermal fischer and then for
providing this opportunity for
us to discuss advancements in urinary
tract
infection testing utis are a very
important clinical problem
and especially with our aging population
and it's becoming
more and more of an issue
the second most common infection among
the elderly and one of the most common
reasons for antibiotic prescriptions
the problem really comes from the bad
outcomes associated with management of
these urinary tract infections
especially in the elderly
over time
and and we see these bad outcomes that
manifest themselves
as increasing numbers of
antibiotic-resistant infections
increased hospitalizations and
neurosepsis uh next slide please
when we look at it from the societal
impact
we can note that this this becomes a
very very important clinical problem
um
it results in approximately 10 and a
half million
office visits annually and accounts for
almost 50 of all medicare missions from
long-term uh health care
centers and when we look at it in total
what we really see is a 13 billion
dollar impact
in the health care system
clinicians especially urologists who
have uti infections as a as a primary
function uh focus really see the impact
in their own office settings if you look
at the standard urology practice up to
50 of all of their office time during
the day
um is focused around managing
these very common infections but common
infections that once again can have
significant
bad outcomes for example we know that a
third of infections
uh currently illustrate resistance to
antibiotics and we're seeing a dramatic
increases
in the number of patients
who are showing not only
antibiotic-resistant bacteria
but also a large number of cases of
urosepsis associated
with
the the
improper or
ill-advised management of these
infections
next slide please
so
let's kind of walk our way through
how this solution was developed
and
work through then some of the evidence
associated with the development of this
test and where we really see it's going
um a lot of this is probably important
to put in context to a significant
change um
in how urinary tract infections are
viewed in general
if we were to go back in even four or
five years we would note that in medical
schools it is still common to teach that
urine is sterile
and that urinary tract infections are
caused by one or two organisms
in fact three or more organisms uh based
on current microbiology guidelines are
actually uh considered uh contaminated
specimens
so as we look at this it's important to
understand that we're going through
an evolution not only in testing
methodologies
but in the thought press process uh
revolving around what is an actual
infection what are its constituents
and how does this all work in context
and it all basically goes back to
standard urine culture
if we consider the the data sets that
have been developed
um over the last hundred years they all
revolve around the standard urine
culture where you taste take basically
an aggro plate you're going to streak
organisms from a urine sample across
that plate if it grows up overnight it's
positive if nothing grows up it's
negative the problem is is this is
produced what uh dr wolf has described
out of loyola university
as an e coli centric vision of the
universe because frankly
what we see from standard urine culture
isn't so much a representation of what
organisms may be driving the infection
but what organisms from that urine
sample were able to grow on the agar
plate
so what we see then is
is in many ways a biased result because
what we're doing is showing what we can
see
rather than what's actually there
this really
led to the development of this what we
call our guidance uti diagnostic
solution and the whole point of it is is
what we really need to understand is
is in these patients
who are symptomatic and this is very
important these types of tests are not
an appropriate way to look at
patients who are not presenting with
symptoms this is this isn't a screening
test this is really a test designed to
look at patients who are presenting with
system uh symptoms consistent with
urinary tract infection
and asking a very important question
what organisms are actually driving this
infection because i mean what we're
really seeing in the bladder in essence
is the dysbiosis you know we're in a
situation where where many of these
patients have a
uh microbiome
and there's been a disruption this
microbiome we now have
growth of a subset of organisms that
normally might not be found there or at
least in those proportions
and so now we want to ask a dynamic
question
what organisms bacterial viral or fungal
may be present in that urine sample that
is driving this infection
so the original
test that we developed with thermal
fissure about six years ago looked at a
small subset of organisms which at the
time
were thought to be driving urinary tract
infections
over the last several years as the
academic
research has driven a better
understanding of what organisms might be
causative
this panel is expanded
and it now represents a large subset of
gram-positive and gram-negative
organisms that would normally
be missed by standard urine culture
but it's great we've identified
something
how does that
reflect how then you treat how do you
develop a treatment algorithm
derived
just from the genetic information found
within that sample well the truth is
it's not only difficult it probably uh
produces an inaccurate result so we
started with the nor the idea we were
going to look at only organisms so we
idv the sample
we then looked at the presence or
absence of antibiotic resistance genes
here's where the challenge started so
we we look back five years we've
identified the organism we've looked at
trying to develop a panel before
antibiotic resistance genes
but the challenge was really twofold
first of all
not all antibiotic resistance genes for
all of these organisms been identified
at the same time
we're going to see situations where you
can identify an antibiotic resistance
gene
but you actually don't have
susceptibility
why well it's basic genetics in many
cases the presence or absence of a
a dna sequence
does not necessarily correspond to
whether or not it's functional and to
the degree which
um it's expressed
and these three conundrums so what we
basically found
and and in a paper that's uh being
released in the next couple of weeks
what we've basically been shown is about
40 of the time
um there is a discord result between the
presence or absence of antibiotic
resistance genes
and actual antibiotic susceptibility
about 20 of the time
we find an antibiotic resistance
gene but just don't see
resistance at about 20 percent of the
time we get resistance in the absence
of an antibiotic resistance gene
so then how do we come up with a
functional result because it's all
really about treating the patient
so
we went back to the biological question
we were looking at and it was clear that
culture was missing a significant number
of organisms so isn't the question if
you have this
dysbiotic
condition
rather than what organism is causing the
infection perhaps the better question is
is what combination of organisms
are driving an infection and doesn't the
treatment then have to be tailored
to answer that important biological
question so we developed what we termed
a pooled antibiotic susceptibility test
and basically what this test is is it it
queries the urine and asks a basic
question what antibiotic
will get rid of these uropathogens that
have been identified
in such a way that we can disrupt this
dysbiotic condition and in doing so
have a much better likelihood of
actually having
a real result when you treat the patient
next slide please
from a methodological standpoint the ig
and antibiotic resistance
test is very straightforward you're
basically taking urine sample you're
doing a dna extraction
we then identify the pathogens and
antibiotic resistance genes in this
particular case we look at 41 specific
organisms and over 30 antibiotic
resistance genes from seven different
classes
this produces that once again very
important information what is it and
what antibiotic resistance genes are
present but now we we further then want
to look at the question of
so what is the appropriate antibiotic to
actually treat this group of organisms
that we see
next slide please
and when we look at it this is where
this pooled antibiotic susceptibility
test really comes into play
because what we do know is
is if we have several groups
of organisms found together
that these bacterial interactions
can drive significant changes in
antibiotic susceptibility both
upregulating and down regulating
antibiotic susceptibility
merely due to the presence of these
additional species
and and really once again this is a this
is you know a
in vivo phenomena that we're really you
know tapping into because we understand
that when they work together they're
gonna share metabolic byproducts they do
this under stress and ways to try to
manage um
this new challenge that they face the
presence of an antibiotic how can we now
survive in doing in this environment and
to survive it what they basically say is
let's cooperate let's work together so
what we've been able to identify through
this process and and
is
already been published is basically data
that suggests that there is a
significant subset of paradigm groups of
organisms
that have different antibody
susceptibility testing in the presence
of these additional organisms and this
is really consistent with other
peer-reviewed work that's come out over
the last decade or more
next slide please
so how does this actually turn into a
clinical result
so let's look at how we try to pair
the id and presence of antibiotic
resistance genes
with the susceptibility
and
clinical practice standards in an
algorithmic approach to to try to come
up with what is the best choice with
respect to antibiotics when you're
trying to manage these patients
and this recognizes the fact that
especially in the elderly population
we're going to see a large number of
these poly microbial
infections so let's let's take a look at
this report and start with the the
part at the top where we're basically
looking in this particular case we had
four organisms found within this
patient's urine once again as we
recognize this it's probably also
important to understand
that in this particular case since since
standard urine culture is what this test
is based on there's a very linear
relationship between cfus that would be
traditionally i identified using a
standard urine culture report
and our cells per ml here we basically
see a direct relationship between cfus
and cells per ml so when we say 100 000
cells per mil this would have
corresponded to the um 100 000 that
would normally be seen during using a
standard urine culture
so we have four
four organisms found in this particular
case so it's a polymicrobial infection
um we tested against 19 different
antibiotic or antibiotic combinations
um
in our
in our report and how it's
set up
the antibiotic that produce the best
result would be on the left hand side
and then the right hand side so as we
move to the right
these become
less of a preferred preferred antibiotic
based on this specific patient pattern
so once again this is basically
as you would say the old personalized
medicine
approach
for these organisms cipro in this
particular case worked out to be the
best choice
from a formulation standpoint we always
will
prefer oral over iv
options if they're available
sensitive
104 is always preferred over resistance
so here we have a case where
we have
for these particular four organisms an
oral formulation where we have a series
of these formulations that have
demonstrated uh sensitivity respect to
the four organisms that we see
we're always going to prefer situations
where there was no antibiotic resistance
genes found within that population so
sensitive no antibiotic resistance chain
will be preferred over sensitive and the
presence of a resistance chain
beneath that is the mick results for
these
finally
it's also important to understand with
some of these organisms there may or may
not be clinical information that
supports the use of this particular
antibiotic with this particular group of
organisms so as we see here
these four
organisms in this particular case
had clinical recommendations for used
with cipro demonstrated a pooled
sensitivity result had an oral
formulation available and no antibiotic
resistance genes
um present
so that's basically provides an
understanding of how we put these uh
together
um so
when we look at this
um what we basically find in about 41
percent of the time we're going to find
a
antibiotic found here that would be more
effective than if we used to enter in
culture
things that traditionally would not be
seen together
next slide please
so let's kind of look at some of the
challenges that this test provides uh
first of all um
from an accuracy standpoint we're going
to see that pcr clearly um
provides more accurate results
both from a sensitivity and specificity
standpoint especially with respect to
sensitivity where
we see that
using this method we're going to see
about 43 percent
more bacteria than we would have seen
using standard urine culture
most importantly however there's a time
component here that's very important
standard hearing culture going from
three to five days
where we typically can produce results
roughly in about 24 hours with our
current methodology
probably worth noting as we move into
the fall
with an enhanced methodology we see this
result coming down to about 14 to 16
hours
next slide please
so which patient's benefit uh well once
again you know we started this
conversation with with the fact that
um
this isn't a screening test this isn't
meant you know as as a screen because
what you're going to find is and
especially now that we understand
that patients have microbiomes and these
microbiomes
may often contain organisms that we
might describe as as your pathogens so
so for example patients with
asymptomatic bacteria very clearly
may be found with very high accounts for
e coli and other what we would call
traditional uropathogens
but without presenting symptoms i mean
there's there's there's clearly
a relationship that is occurring between
the microbiome and these
what we would other wise term
pathogens
that we don't want to disrupt so what
we're really looking at is how do we how
do we use this test appropriately first
of all we want to use it in symptomatic
patients
we want to look specifically or very
clearly patients with recurrent and
persistent urinary tract infections
especially those that are advantaged by
culture why because we understand that
the very
a very likely reason why
they may have persistent infections is
because the culture is otherwise missing
organisms that might have been managed
if the test had been more sensitive and
specific
uh clearly you would want to use this on
patients with
negative urine cultures but were still
symptomatic
so also very well suited for
catheterized patients in patients with
incontinence and especially with
patients with known antibiotic allergies
next slide
please um to this day we've completed
four large
clinical trials
to support the development of this work
we did a original internal validation
um our first
clear study was a 500 patient clinical
validity study that was done
um on patients 60 and older uh
our first large randomized trial was a
prospective trial um with three arms
where we looked at 2518 patients
from 37 urology offices in seven states
with a mean age of 73
where we compared the clinical outcomes
of treated patients based on culture
or our guidance utility result
and then most recently we looked at a 66
000 patient cohort retrospective study
where we were looking especially at
rates of hospitalization emergency room
visits
in this population
next slide please
um these studies have resulted in a
number of peer-reviewed publications
basically looking at clinical validity
uh analytical ability and then
clinical
uh utility
uh what we've basically been able to
demonstrate over time is
is the test uh is both sensitive and
specific and from a clinical outcome
standpoint
um as we're going to see has resulted in
a significant reduction in emergency
room and hospitalizations
associated with performance of the test
um at the same time
we've started to describe
mechanistically
um
the development of or the identification
of groups of organisms
and these groups of organisms
have been able to be demonstrated that
over time that the presence or absence
of certain of these pairs significantly
uh increase or decrease the
antibiotic susceptibility
characteristics of these uh
groups of organisms next slide please
um let's look at some of the data
identified here one of the things we
note
significantly and there's a group of
organisms not detected by standard urine
culture that we are seeing
using this methodology once again
suggesting that there is a
significant prominent miss using
standard urine culture as a pair as
compared to a molecular methodologies
next slide please
and that this miss often manifests
itself in missing what would otherwise
be termed polymicrobial infections
when we look at these cases in general
especially when we look at
patient populations above age 65 we're
going to find a significant population
our polymicrobial nature in this
particular case about 56 percent of all
cases identified in this population of
poly microbial in nature
and when we compare this methodology to
what we would see to standard urine
culture
we see that saturn urine culture is
going to miss about four out of every
five polymicrobial infections
um
how does this impact things what we
would find is that about one in five
times
by not having the correct identification
we would have missed
the correct antibiotic next slide please
let's look at some of these specific
interactions and and how they may change
outcomes
so once again we we've identified 13
specific bacterial pairs that are
commonly found
they change these interaction patterns
if you look
in the
first
graph on the left
it gives a fairly interesting phenomena
in about 30 percent of our cases
uh
with supple core we would have seen a uh
antibiotic uh
uh resistance
uh
for e coli roughly about 20 percent with
klebsiella when we look at these found
together there's a significant additive
effect where we find that upwards of 50
or more of these
organisms when they're found in pairs
are known
demonstrating resistance at the same
time we can see down regulation
so when we look at tetracycline upwards
of forty percent of the case is
devastating tetracycline resistance
roughly twenty percent with club seattle
but when we look at them together we see
a decrease
in resistance
with respect to e coli and an increase
in resistance
with respect to klebsiella
um and once again these phenomena have
been shown to be
reproducible
and we began studies to look at these
from a mechanistic standpoint to
understand what's
happening from an interactional
uh level that might be driving this
process very important finding however
though because the challenges is is if
you were looking these as just results
from pure culture and looking at e coli
and looking susceptibility patterns
um we clearly would be missing something
with respect to
how we would have looked at this data
next slide please
so let's look some real world data
and this was probably looking at
roughly a hundred thousand cases worth
of data over 12 month period
where a standard urine culture would
have missed eight types of bacteria in
all the samples
it would have missed about fifty hundred
samples with fastidis bacteria
it most importantly would have missed
seventeen thousand cases of
polymicrobial infections
with over 9000
having
uh different pairs of oranges that would
have changed the susceptibility patterns
to antibiotics if you had known they've
been present
so what really would have happened stand
agriculture would not have provided the
correct antibiotic choices for that
group of pathogens
and on average it would have taken them
over a day longer to provide the results
and what's the net impact of this what
ultimately
in my mind is the driver of many of
these things is
is our need to
move
time to result faster because frankly
every day that we wait
drives imperial treatment from a
clinician's standpoint if we can move it
from four to five days
to under a day and hopefully eventually
to
you know under 48 hours four to eight
hours now we have a situation
where imperial treatment does not have
to be the first choice that clinicians
reach for when trying to manage these
patients
and once again if
if there is a societal risk
long term not only from utis but really
from all infections
is the common
need for clinicians to
turn to empiric treatment
to manage patients because frankly their
symptoms are acute enough and strong
enough that they don't want to wait to
have to go ahead and intervene
the faster we can get our results out
the more likely we're going to be able
to be able to treat these patients
not only more rapidly but more
accurately next slide please
um from an outcome standpoint from
clinical utilities standpoint when we
look at the results from our 66 000
uh patient study
what we saw was a 13.7
reduction in emergency department and
hospital visits per year
and roughly 22 reduction in costs
um
in
developing data that worth looking at
now
from a more significant population we
find that those reactions are even more
dramatic
next slide please
and once again i think the drive to all
of these things you know as we add in
testing
can't be to drive more testing and more
antibiotic
use
ultimately what we need to do
is to be able to have more accurate
tests that provide more reliable results
such that
we reduce the amount of antibiotics
being used and when we do have to use
antibiotics we use them in such a way
that we provide the antibiotic that's
most appropriate for the group of
organisms found rather than the organism
that we believed to have been found
using methodologies that may not have
been as sensitive and specific as we
might have hoped
uh next slide please
um
what we see ultimately is is the
development of molecular methodologies
and combining them with these these
phenotypic studies
have shown a series of advantages to
using these types of approaches
first of all we've seen significant
improvement
from a clinical validity standpoint we
have a much more sensitive and specific
test
because of that
we see vastly more bacteria that are
found there
which have been demonstrated to be
uropathogens as we would have found
previously using standard uric culture
and consequently
from a polymicrobial infection detection
rate
um we see
significantly more polymicrobial
infections that would have been
otherwise seen
using standard urine culture
and perhaps most importantly
we've significantly reduced the
turnaround time
such that we now have a situation where
we're more likely to be able to turn our
result more clinical intervention
is going to have a bigger impact
and hopefully driving less reliance on
empiric treatment